[Musique]
c'est le moment des bois bois tu veux
vous expliquer le principe chaque
chroniqueur à une boîte est plutôt pas
une boîte ils sont pas une boîte
d'ailleurs tu ne bois bois mais il y a
une gousse d'ail une potion magique
faudra boire la potion un week end à
menton avec igor et grichka la tête de
loup garou embrasser un crapaud des
scellés cadeau pourri et les cadeaux aux
manifs au maroc soir week-end dans un
château hanté mais très frais sa tante
et ça veut dire même le room service it
amène jean room service et genre ya 1,9
qui s'auto voilà une console + jeux de
foot
la présentation d'un prime time est un
voyage dans l'espace jean michel vous
les voyages dans l'espace accession à la
tête de ma mère que ça n'est pas le
biseau crapaud c'est le voyage dans
l'espace
[Applaudissements]
non mais
allez-y vous avez partir tout de suite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
marca
auto
en plus c'est un beau cadeau des mails
et téléphone
j'aime bien les télés c'est fou sans ils
m'arrêtent je vous le dirai banon ou
partent en week-end dans un château en
tic
agathe au cou qui parle c'est un poil
ras sera quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gilles veut faire un prime time et bien
gilles avant de faire ce prime time
vous aller embrasser un crapaud
[Applaudissements]
merci m
m
vous allez pouvoir la potion magique
bush toile n'est jamais là plus de
palerme connais pas tout donc ici ce cas
le prime time
pascal lucas des clés de dinars
[Applaudissements]
k
ca
[Musique]